la science démontre de plus en plus que
l'expression péjorative avoir une
cervelle d'oiseau ne pourrait pas être
plus loin de la réalité en fait les
capacités cognitives des oiseaux sont
surprenantes
lui là aucun doute c'est une cervelle
d'oiseau avouons-le ce n'est pas un
compliment mais pour le spécialiste du
comportement animal l'insulte mérite
quelques précisions les oiseaux
pensaient avant que c'était pas
intelligent on pensait que ça va pas le
cerveau pour être aussi intelligent
qu'un ami faire parce qu'il y a pas de
Cortex l'intelligence telle qu'on la
connaît chez un singe vous savez ça
existe j'ai beaucoup d'oiseaux avec un
système nerveux entièrement différent
pourquoi certains oiseaux sont-ils plus
intelligents pourquoi certains sont-ils
innovants c’est-à-dire capables de
trouver une solution à un problème donné
comme ici ou l'oiseau se sert du pain
comme à part Louis Lefebvre expert de la
question a trouvé une partie de la
réponse et c'est en combinant science et
ornithologies amateur qu'il y ait
parvenu
la chose merveilleuse dans l'innovation
c'est que il y a des centaines de
milliers de personnes partout dans le
monde qui aiment les oiseaux qui vont
les observer ils connaissent ce qui est
normal chez un oiseau puis dès qu'il
voit quelque chose qui est pas fréquent
qui est une usité il y a tout une
tradition dans les revues ornithologie à
la fois amateur et professionnel pour
rapporter ces choses inusitées et donc
c'est une banque de données fantastique
dans un récent en papier Louis Lefebvre
et ses collègues expliquent que
l'intelligence aviaire serait le fruit
d'une combinaison celle d'un gros
cerveau et d'un grand nombre de neurones
et ces neurance se situe dans une zone
spécifique le nidopalium codolatéral
un peu comme le cortex préfrontal chez
l'humain le nidopalium Codo latéral et
la région du cervoisière utilisée pour
certaines fonctions comme la
planification l'abstraction et la
résolution de problèmes pour mieux
saisir le rôle de cette structure on a
eu l'idée d'y dénombrer les neurones et
on s'est rendu compte que certains
oiseaux avaient une densité de neurones
supérieure et un nombre de neurones
supérieur à des singes dans des parties
de cerveau équivalentes l'équivalent du
cortex chez un perroquet ou un corbeau
il y a plus de neurones là dedans que
dans l'équivalent chez un singe comme
mettant un macaque ou un capucin il y a
des oiseaux qui en ont un milliard un
presque 2 milliards chez un gros
perroquet presque deux milliards de
neurones dans l'équivalent du cortex
c'est énorme c'est plus dense que ce
qu'on retrouve chez un mammifère du même
poids corporelle
le cerveau étant d'une complexité
remarquable la quantité de neurones
suffit-elle à expliquer l'innovation la
réponse n'est pas si simple sais-tu la
partie du cerveau comme notre cortex
préfrontal c'est tu la taille le volume
ou si tu le nombre de neurones Canada si
tu le nombre de synapse que chaque
neuron fait sais-tu l'expression des
neurotransmetteurs puis de leur
récepteur
[Musique]
chose certaine dans le règne animal la
quasi-totalité des neurones se forment
durant la gestation un paramètre majeur
dans l'expression de l'intelligence
aviaire chez l'humain péché presque tous
les animaux d'ailleurs les oiseaux les
mammifères la très très grande majorité
sinon la totalité des neurones qu'on va
avoir c'est quand on est très très jeune
et donc si on allonge la période de
notre développement on va allonger la
période de neurogénèse les observations
montrent aussi que le temps passé au nid
et l'approvisionnement par les parents
influencent son développement elle est
très fort entre la tête du corps et la
terre du cerveau et le nombre de
neurones donc c'est un gestation est
plus longue ton développement est plus
long tu as plus de neurones qui dans ton
cerveau donc si l'intelligence et
l'innovation c'est une façon de gérer
les changements puis de trouver des
solutions
ça va donner plus de bénéfices à
quelqu'un de gros parce qu'il va
rencontrer plus de changements donc il
va avoir plus besoin ça va l'aider à
survivre et il va avoir les neurones en
plus pour faire ça parce que son temps
de développement arrêté plus long ça
c'est l'idée qui est nouvelle dans
l'article qu'on a publié les travaux de
Louis Lefebvre nous invitent aussi à un
peu de retenue maintenant il est
préférable d'y penser à deux reprises
avant de traiter l'autre de cervelle
d'oiseau